في الساعه السادسه والنصف مساء بالتوقيت
المحلي في تركيا اعلنت الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات في انتهاء الحظر المفروض على
وسائل الاعلام لنشر البيانات الانتخابيه
طبعا النتائج الاوليه ستبدا بالظهور تباعا
وصولا الى منتصف هذه الليله حيث ستتضح
النتيجه النهائيه للانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه هنا في حزب العداله والتنميه
مقر حزب العداله والتنميه في العاصمه
التركيه انقره هناك استعدادات لما نسميه
الاتراك بخطاب الشرفه اي ان حزب العداله
والتنميه توقع الفوز بهذه الانتخابات لذلك
بدات الاستعدادات للاحتفالات في المقر
الرئيسي في العاصمه التركيه انقره ايضا
المشهد مشابه في مقر حزب الشعب الجمهوري
الذي ايضا استعد للفوز او احتفالات الفوز
كما يقول انصار انصار المرشح الرئاسي كمال
سنتابع النتائج معكم اولا باول على شاشتي
العربيه والحدث
[موسيقى]